where did you get that hat where did you
get that tile isn't it - Navi won in
just the proper style I should like to
have one just the same as that wherever
I go they show where did you get that
hat now how I came to get this hat is
very strange and funny my uncle died and
left to me his property and money and
win the will that was ran out they told
me straight and flat if I'm to have his
money I must also wear his hat did you
get that hot where did you get that tile
isn't it - Navi won in just the rubber
style I should like to have one famous
that's where I go they show when I go to
the concert hall in the concert season
there's someone sure to show that me
without the slightest reason when I go
today off - naughty one in just the
proper style
like to where ere I go they show when
mr. and mrs. Ramsbottom had their last
garden party I was amongst two guests to
had a welcome true and hearty the Prince
of Wales was also there and my heart
jumped with glee when someone said the
prince would like to have a word with me
that's where I go they shall